I could have my tummy out even if it's  just  a clout and if you got something to say  shut your mouth cause I'm a hot  I'm sorry I should have warned you if  you were eating here's what's wrong with  it it's not just oh this is a big girl  look if someone is big and they're  working on themselves no one has a  problem with it no one here has ever  made fun of someone for just being big  she says even if it's for chasing clouds  so what is happening we've now taken fat  pride and what is it it's just vanity  in a dishonest way in other words people  used to be vain because they thought  they were very very good looking right  they were they were uh desirable now  it's false vanity and it's demand it's a  demand that you find them attract this  is not good it's not healthy and where's  the fact checking where's the fact  checking CDC that actually being uh  morbidly obese is unhealthy and uh leads  to and then insert problems here